some airline passengers are really not
happy about an airline's new policy of
weighing passengers this is to American
Samoan businessmen who have filed
complaints with the US Transportation
Department saying that they were weighed
before they boarded a flight from
Honolulu and assigned specific seats to
keep the aircraft load evenly
distributed this is according to Radio
New Zealand Hawaiian Airlines is new
policy which is a response they say to
the average increase in passenger weight
met that anybody flying to or from Pago
Pago the capital of American Samoa can
no longer choose their own seats online
and they may have to be weighed before
boarding the plane so that airline staff
can decide where on the plane they
should sit for proper weight
distribution the airline told a radio
station that the increased girth of the
typical passenger means they now need to
distribute weight in a very particular
way on their Boeing 767 cabins to meet
the manufacturer guidelines and this
means the number of adults per row need
to be limited
we need to reserve seats in certain rows
for young children and additionally
particularly heavy passengers need to be
distributed in a very particular way
however of a mullah Dave Halleck who's
one of the two businessmen who was
involved and upset here believes that
this is a discriminatory rule because it
applies only to those flying tour from
American Samoa why why would this
involve people frying flying tour from
American Samoa well you might not know
this but American Samoa has the highest
rate of obesity in the world something
like 75 percent of adults are considered
obese and that is actually old data from
about eight years ago some say that over
90% of the American Samoan population
currently is obese Samoa air three years
ago was the first airline to change how
they would charge passengers charging
passengers based on their size and many
people are upset about this but I I'm
not just sure I'm not sure about the
being upset thing because listen number
one
wait on an airplane is an issue there
there are two really important ways in
which weight impacts an airplane one is
total weight at takeoff and landing
which changes because you burn fuel
during the flight and you've got to be
aware of both your takeoff weight and
your landing weight and number two the
distribution of weight within the plane
is very very important and for small
planes being overloaded or overweight or
having uneven weight distribution is a
huge risk and it causes accidents larger
planes have more of a tolerance but this
is objectively speaking a major safety
issue further it is backed by data that
American Samoa has an extremely high
obesity rate and if you imagine you know
the unbalance the airline is counting on
the fact that for every overweight
person you have some tolerance and
you'll have someone who's thin or a kid
or someone with no luggage or something
like that if 90% of the population in a
particular place is obese this becomes a
mathematical question so I don't know
Rachel what do you is there something to
be offended about here I don't believe
so but there was a man last year who was
flying on American Airlines and he
claimed that he was kicked off for being
overweight because the woman next to him
was saying he didn't fit correctly in
the seat and he was kind of spilling
over into her seat yes this whole
controversy about it he said he felt
like he was treated like a fat criminal
so I do think if it's done in that way
it should probably be avoided however I
don't know if this is completely
discriminatory and another thing also is
that I think if the catalyst is safety
then that's critical that's important
however I know Ryan air which is a
historically sketchy European airline
company is a huge proponent of this tax
but the way that they want to do it is
to charge people for every pound that
they are overweight right yeah and and
I've had experiences where I was sitting
next to a passenger of size and you know
that at its base at its most base
analysis I paid for an entire seat on
the flight and that includes the width
of the seat and because I was up against
a window and next to a passenger of size
I did not have an entire seat actually
speaking did
have an entire seat so from a passenger
rights perspective if I paid for an
entire seat and I didn't have an entire
seat you would think that there's
something there that has to be dealt
with on the same hand if you as a
passenger of size paid for one seat and
are occupying a seat and a half or two
you could make the same argument there
and some airlines have started to go
that route which is if at check-in you
are observed to be larger than one seats
with or sighs then you are told you're
going to have to buy two two tickets
that is separate then you know if one or
two passengers of size on a plane are
not going to cause a safety issue but
they are going to inconvenience a couple
of people sitting next to them that is
very very different what I'm seeing here
with the Hawaiian airline stuff it does
appear to be primarily based on a safety
issue and really guys why would an
airline all of a sudden come up with
this just a fat shame if it doesn't
present any kind of issue I mean aren't
Airlines busy enough than to put in fat
shaming policies I don't know